voilà ça y est c'est le grand jour c'est
le jour de ma sixième séances de
détatouage au laser c'est à dire le jour
demain dernières séances de détatouage
au laser non c'est faux ça aurait dû
être ma dernière séance
manifestement très clairement ça le sera
pas on va reparler de tout ça
[Musique]
proposent avant de commencer avant
d'aller me faire laser is et les fesses
je propose juste de faire le point sur
deux trois petits trucs déjà il ya
énormément de gens qui l'envoie des
vidéos de personnes qui se font retirer
des tatouages au laser et pour lesquels
ça marche
visuellement de façon à ces ihu fait
donc déjà merci de vous préoccuper de
mon sort à ce point là juste je voulais
rappeler un petit truc ce qu'on voit sur
le détatouage quand on passe le laser
dessus cette espèce de truc blanchâtre
qui se passe c'est pas lancre qui
disparaît instantanément
c'est juste du gaz qui se forme entre
laser et l'on craint ce cancre éclatent
çà fait une espèce de gaz qui remonte à
la surface de la peau mais qui reste
quelques heures et après ça s'en va et
le tatouage reprend son son éclat après
il faut plusieurs jours voire plusieurs
semaines voire plusieurs mois pour que
lancre de toute façon soit éliminé du
corps donc ça a l'air miraculeux comme
ça mais non ça ne l'est pas d'ailleurs
si vous souvenez deux images de ma
première séance de laser à moi ça
faisait un petit peu ce truc là on sait
ce qui s'est passé depuis
ensuite ya pas mal de gens qui
s'inquiètent qui disent oui mais tu es
en train de te faire arnaquer le mct à
10 6 séances et puis finalement
maintenant ils te disent et c'est bon
c'est vrai qu'au départ quand on a
discuté il m'a dit on part sur six
séances en se renseignant un petit peu
en discutant avec des gens qui se sont
fait des tatoués en regardant un petit
peu ce qui se passe de plus près
manifestement six séances c'est de toute
façon deux basques quelque chose de
vraiment c'est un minimum
donc si vous êtes dans mon cas si vous
avez un tatouage à vous faire retirer
partez quand même plutôt du principe que
vous êtes parti pour deux ans plutôt
qu'à un an ça c'est plus raisonnable
en tout cas si vous utiliser la même
technique que celle que j'ai choisie
ensuite c'est peut-être pas mal de
préciser qui a probablement trois
raisons qui expliquent que c'est un
petit peu d'eau dans mon cas d'abord la
qualité de l'encré
le médecin a insisté sur ce point là ils
sont pas toutes équivalentes là
manifestement mais sur une ancre de
bonne qualité donc merci à julien et ama
qui ont fait la gentillesse de me
tatouer la fesse on est sur du bon matos
ensuite il ya la quantité d'encre
on est d'accord que le laser ça fait
exploser lancre qui ensuite et
illuminait mais plus il ya d'encre à
faire exploser plus c'est long ça se
passe couche par couche
encore une fois merci julien et hama
vous avez mis la bonne dose je suis à
deux doigts de me demander si vous
voulez pas fait exprès un petit peu pour
me pour le punir
non c'est faux ils sont le musée nous
ont vraiment beaucoup trop sympa pour
avoir fait ça mais en tout cas la
quantité d'encre
ça joue aussi et puis dernier point je
fais le tatouage deux mois après je me
faisais des tatoués donc c'est un
tatouage qui est très frais
donc c'est une encre qui est toute
fraîche donc peut-être que c'est plus
compliqué que pour un tatouage un peu
vieux dont l'encré déjà un peu passé
déjà un peu déjà un petit peu dégradée
gardons ça en mémoire depuis quand même
un cas un tout petit peu particulier
même si ça peut arriver de se faire
retirer tout de suite un tatouage
quand on constate une catastrophe mais
bon gardez ça quand même en mémoire aux
trucs à bien avoir à l'esprit aussi j'ai
pas choisi un laser de compétition j'ai
pas pris le laser le plus puissant qui
existent au monde pourra me faire
détatouer
[Musique]
j'ai pris un coup switch donc un truc
assez basique assez classique le truc le
plus le plus répandu en fait mais pas le
plus balèze ya par exemple un laser qui
s'appelle le laser pico shourd qui est
réputé pour faire partir les tatouages
en deux fois moins de séances que les
autres c'est aussi beaucoup plus cher
donc moi je suis vraiment parti dans
l'idée de tester le truc qui était
accessible à tous même si je vous
rappelle que on est quand même sur 150
euros la séance donc déjà avec nos trucs
basiques c'est déjà un vrai budget mais
en tout des voilages moi j'avais pris le
parti de tester le truc le plus répandu
est pas forcément le plus efficace donc
garder ça à l'esprit
j'avoue avec le recul du coup je me dis
vu le nom de séance que je vais faire je
me demande si financièrement même avec
l'autre qui est beaucoup plus cher mais
s'ils marchent plus vite ça aurait pas
été intéressant mais en tout cas voilà
ça valide le fait que ça valait le coup
que je sacrifie mes fesses pour vous
donner des infos fiables à la parce que
là je sais très exactement comment ça se
passe vous voyez-vous très précisément
comment ça se passe et vous voyez
combien ça coûte combien de temps ça
dure et c'est donc je vais aller
jusqu'au bout un jeu vous a demandé la
dernière fois et vous avez été plutôt en
faveur de continuer la même méthode donc
je vais aller au bout de cette méthode
qui t'a va repartir pour un pour dix
mois
on verra bien à la fin mais je je je
persiste j'ai aussi échanger des gens
qui ont eu la même expérience que moi de
détatouage au laser
il ya plusieurs personnes qui m'ont dit
franchement de toute façon vaut mieux
prendre son temps avec une méthode qui
au final
t'inquiète pas ça finira par un marché
plutôt que de faire des trucs vraiment
hardcore et de se retrouver avec des
cicatrices moche ou la peau vraiment
abîmé donc du coup c'est peut-être pas
plus mal que ça prenne son temps là
j'avoue c'est vrai ça prend vraiment son
temps mais comme plusieurs d'entre vous
me l'ont fait remarquer c'est pour avoir
la tête d'hanouna en cicatrice sur les
fesses au bout du compte c'est peut-être
pas la peine non plus mais bon donc je
reste tranquille je reste confiant ça va
finir par partir
c'est juste clos c'est vrai douloureux
aussi parce que non mais c'est la dure
pas longtemps c'est alors qu'une fois
que la séance est terminée
ça chauffe mais voilà c'est pas à ça
c'est pas une douleur atroce pendant des
jours quoi c'est une douleur atroce
pendant les trois minutes de la séance
et puis bon effectivement c'est un petit
peu cher mais je reste confiant
d'ailleurs en vrai ça commence un petit
peu a marché un jeu parce que vous vous
souvenez de la photo de la dernière fois
vous voyez ça c'est la faute au juste
après la séance de tatouage
vous voyez le tracé est nickel et tout
ça c'est la photo de ma dernière de ma
dernière séance
voyez juste là ce petit trail a
clairement ce petit trait est partie 1
donc si ça fait ça à terme partout ce
sera gagné donc cool et puis encore une
fois si vraiment à la fin ça n'a pas
marché du tout j'ai toujours encore
l'option 1 de tester un autre laser
alors ça ça peut se faire et l'option de
recouvrir le tatouage
alors faudra que je j'envisage un truc
un petit peu plus ambitieux parce que je
vais pas forcément le l'idée d'avoir un
tatouage uniquement sur ma fait ce sera
peut-être un truc un petit peu plus
grand j'ai toujours cette option là donc
voilà je peux restons sereins on l'a
soyez le autant que moi bon maintenant
qu'on a dit tout ça bah qu'est ce qu'on
fait je vais partir à mon rendez vous
vous venez avec moi comme d'habitude
vous allez voir à quoi ça ressemble et
puis on se retrouve après
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est cool de feu dans le
ciel
la rue
oui
[Musique]
alors j'ai pas forcément des bonnes
nouvelles
je vais mettre à l'abri parce qu'il
pleut en vrai je vais prendre le train
parce que je pars en week end
comme vous savez tout je vous raconte
tout ça
bon donc lazare le passé une heure à 6
dans le 30 à la meilleure aide
alors voilà donc qu'est ce qui s'est
passé vous avez vu j'étais plutôt
remonté par les discussions j'avais vu
avec certains d'entre vous j'étais un
peu en mode auto conditionnement pensée
positive machin etc
et puis là à la fin de la séance donc
quand vous avez vu ça à appliquer un
petit peu comme d'habitude je vous
montrera tout à l'heure ça même bien
bien piqué à la fin de la séance
le médecin me dit pour tout vous dire je
suis un petit peu inquiet donc moi
j'étais en mode tout sourire elle a tout
d'un coup on ne s'écroule évidemment
j'ai dit avant ce qui se passe et ils
m'expliquent me dit je trouve que
veulent les traits sont en train de
brunir et qui réagissent de moins en
moins donc j'ai dit qu'est ce que
comment pour qu'est ce que ça signifie
en fait finalement il dit mais j'ai
l'impression que l'encré est de moins en
moins réceptive réagi de moins en moins
au laser ce qui veut dire que
potentiellement le laser fonctionne de
moins en moins bien sûr lancre bon il
est pas affirmatif à 100% mais il voit
là il pense que potentiellement la
composition de lancre ne réagit pas bien
au laser qu'on utilise donc il m'a dit
on on continue quand même envers la
prochaine fois ce que ça donne mais
voilà donc ça m'a un petit peu refroidi
quand même vous le cache pas donc notre
petit rituel désormais voilà donc le
tatouage avant la séance
voilà deux tatouages juste après la
séance quand j'ai retiré le pansement
donc comme vous voyez il ya des belles
petites cloques hearts a bien bien piqué
voilà le tatouage le lendemain donc
vingt-quatre heures après et voilà le
tatouage 48 heures après je sais pas si
vous vous souvenez
je vous avais expliqué dans une première
vidéo comment ça fonctionne exactement
le laser là pour savoir si cette séance
a fonctionné il faudra comparer la
prochaine fois faut laisser un laps de
temps vous souvenez le laser il fait
exploser lancre en plein de petites
particules suffisamment petit pour que
des cellules appelées macrophages puisse
les bouffer et les éliminés après donc
ça n'est pas immédiat faut quelques
semaines pour que pour que ça fonctionne
donc pour que ce soit visible
donc on verra la prochaine fois si ça ça
a fonctionné un petit peu d'ailleurs
alors fun fact les macrophages
vous savez par on les élimine lancre
qu'il bouffe
elle va notamment et principalement par
le caca donc je chie littéralement cyril
hanouna depuis plus d'un an maintenant
voilà je vous laisse là dessus on se
retrouve bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo
d'ici là bas qu'est ce qui vous qu'est
ce qu'on fait mettez vous bien et puis
portez vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]